je t'ai dans une petite école ici on
avait pris une école compose de
commandes représente hustache la jeune
policier qui était mais complètement
mais complet il tremblait comme ça il
n'était pas bien mais gens me disent on
a quelqu'un qui va pas bien racheté
aller m'asseoir sur les petits bancs
d'école j'ai vraiment les petits bancs
et que je suis assis sur un banc d'école
avec l'église et moi ça va mon grand aïe
ça va pas bien et qu'il y avait de la
difficulté
finalement je les retourne à son poste
là j'ai dit bon au milieu des lianes
autorise le schéma des deux policiers
passés à se ramasser ses équipements on
le retourne à son passe plus je marchais
dans la cour d'école je me souviens et
puis je me disais c'est pas
l'enseignement la situation on a vécu
ici c'est pas l'enseignement qu'on donne
à nos policiers ils vivaient quelque
chose de surréel extraordinaire dans le
sens que ça dépassait tout le monde
quand on essaie d'inculquer des
policiers une philosophie d'intervention
policière de respect de pilotes intègre
le sens de la police communautaire
il était ici avec des 6,7 de l'armée
avec les sables 15 20 policiers dans sap
ici les indiens sans viande puisque vous
le feuilletez sur les autres c'est de la
guerre ça ça s'approche
ça s'approche d'une guerre civile qu'est
ce qui s'est passé ici là alors tu es
policiers l'éducation puis les a fait la
formation que de tous toujours enseigné
mais c'est contraire à tout ce qu'on et
après faire du sine